[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
huh
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
stripped it away
pastor jackson now with the d
playing soft off him he might have been
better off taking it to the hoop
instead of settling for the jumper
ah
[Applause]
pass to newton to the left wing
not shot from outside there's no doubt
about that spreading the floor
and getting them up
[Applause]
[Applause]
well they'll be happy with that look
even though
it didn't fall you're right he take that
10 out of 10 times he's not going to
miss many of those
i love his shot selection today he set
the bar
for the rest of the team
shots are just flowing for him right now
having a really
strong quarter
stolen
[Applause]
he has been so big here in the fourth
quarter
five of six from the field
here's the lob to the hoop
jackson trying to break free sent away
gotta have more of this moving forward
portis has the size
needed to turn back shots
[Applause]
there's the dish to jackson
some players might wear down during this
kind of run he's only getting stronger
this is the jackson over to the left
wing
and here in the fourth he's carrying
this team right now five of seven
from the field
to the left wing with the roll he's on
this quarter
they're going to keep going to him get
that lead even bigger
out left of the wing
what a huge boost he's giving them here
four or five in this fourth quarter has
come up big
now the pass to newton
back to jackson
and with the game and the balance here
in the fourth he's been unflappable
six of eight from the field providing
them with some big
buckets
jackson trying to break free how about
these big shots
for him in the fourth he has been locked
and loaded
offensively
to the paint
[Applause]
another steal and that goes out of
bounds
and they retain possession
you